hello good afternoon and John AIT from
focus on a globe I was just moderating a
session on social media and Asia from
shaping norms of influencing policy we
are fed a wide and a range of issues a
few things are worth mentioning we
thought we start talking about the
business model of social media I think
it's clear one thing that's players that
it's still a work in progress no
particular company has yet been able to
find a model that works but I think he
think that being away with this I mean
you are creative product and sticky and
run and then basically certify balls
chief advertisers but I don't believe
anyone propose a sort of most
subscription-based revenue model I just
yes that's on the business side on the
other side we talked a lot about the
impact of what the media have had on the
industry's one area is in businesses
social media has basically transformed
the way this is the market their
products sell their products distribute
their products and also deal with your
customers you see some still a lot of
hesitation from businesses and being
able to embrace this technology have
lights are in agreement that the
business has not been able to embrace
this they've actually excelent succeeded
so hopefully we see more Marc Anthony
the other another area beyond social
media that flute the media has had an
impact on governance we talked about how
social media has affected the politics
of Singapore also in the US but I think
similar to me the business has a lot of
politicians are still more so just
learning to to use and embrace this or
for sort of an apparently a lot of
pockets are coming to realize that
there's really no way around it if
social media is really here to stay is
inevitable to really change the way that
politics goes on so that will also
also change the other issue that cut a
lot of attention is on the issue of
privacy how your consumers deal with the
issue of privacy given that so much more
of the information now available online
there was not leak insensitive to debate
on so what is tolerable but I think one
interesting thing to notice that we all
agreed that consumers will learn in many
ways the way I would frame it is that we
talk a lot about consumer rights right
but i think there's lots of talk but
consumer responsibilities i guess
because we are bright doesn't give us a
license it is stupid and of course
everything that you have all your
information on quests that you have to
be reasonable and what you do post on
the website and realize that some of
these things there is a risk but that
big week that the i can do about using
your data and some maybe even a third
party is using that information so i
think as people get more and more
comfortable in dealing with social media
there will also be a lot smarter and
also a lot more responsible and what
they do this project but they don't
disclose so these are just some some of
the things we talked about what's clear
i think is that social media is here to
stay there is no debate as to whether
social media with a bad i think is that
everyone agree that social media is here
to stay the question was you know how do
we then deal with how do we make money
out of it how do businesses adopt
through it so this will be a question i
think will be answered over the next
maybe 20 30 years but it's today we were
able to start a discussion on that
that's that's it for me thank you